[Musique]
sortir de l'atelier de l'enseignement
exposer son oeuvre au regard de l'autre
avec graine d'artiste les élèves de
l'école municipale d'arts plastiques
présente une création réalisée au cours
de l'année globalement le travail qu'il
choisit c'est un travail quand même que
eux estiment assez aboutis et justement
cette question de l'aboutissement c'est
quelque chose qu'on travaille aussi avec
avec les élèves que les enseignants
travaillent avec les élèves
c'est à dire c'est aussi le regard
apprendre à l'élève à regarder sont
ravis sculptures peintures dessins et
arts plastiques
plus de 150 oeuvres autour d'un même
thème celui de la métamorphose une
transformation de matière d'objets
d'époque pour trompé l'oeil du
spectateur
l'idée avec ce fil rouge de la
métamorphose c'est de proposer un cadre
un cadre d'action qui leur permettent de
s'exprimer sur la notion de
transformation
évidemment la métamorphose en arts
plastiques
c'est assez courant quelque chose qu'on
pratique de manière assez naturelle
puisqu'on est déjà dans la
transformation de la matière
la métamorphose aller d'une part dans
l'intention de l'artiste dans
l'intention de celui qui pratique mais
elle peut être aussi dans le regard de
celui qui voit le qui voit le travail
graines d'artistes et comme une
rétrospective de l'année écoulée
un premier pas sous les projecteurs pour
ces artistes dont les plus jeunes non
seulement quatre ans
[Musique]
non